the blockchain world has given us so
many amazing opportunities to think
about not just owning our own money but
owning our own data
owning our communications owning the way
that we relate to each other
blockchain redefines what we can build
who we can build it for and how we can
build it every single thing that Wall
Street and many other industries are
doing is now getting digitized and being
a programmable which presages a
revolution that is going to be as large
as the internet revolution in our view
I'm really passionate about the
technology cuz I think it has the
potential to really change people's
lives for the better we're gonna get to
a point ten years from now that people
are gonna look back and have a hard time
remembering how business was conducted
without watching as its foundation if
you are concerned that hey this might
disrupt my business this might disrupt
my job then learn everything you can
about this particular technology and
you're gonna be better off for it
there's an incredible need for
experienced developers like you join the
next technological revolution on the
ground floor take the leap and reinvent
yourself as a blockchain dev with
Udacity s blockchain developer nano
degree throughout the nanodegree you'll
complete your own story blockchain
projects and finish the program with a
portfolio ready to show employers you'll
build your own blockchain to store and
manage data create your own smart
contracts using aetherium solidity
language and build a blockchain powered
web app for supply chain management
come join the blockchain revolution
[Music]
you